hier ist unsere Fragenlotterie du weißt es
okay du kannst wählen lass mich ein Risiko
eingehen okay sollte ich es öffnen ja bitte und jetzt
kannst du wieder mit mir reden bist du nur ein
Eins-Zwei-Drei-Hit-Wunder Nun, ich denke,
das ist nichts für mich, ist es nicht  Eine knifflige
Frage, weil ich so glücklich darüber bin,
was mit dir passiert ist. Weißt du nicht,
weil es für mich ein
himmelweiter Unterschied ist, ob ich einen großen Song oder zwei große Songs habe, also weil One Hit Wonder ein sehr bekanntes Wort ist, aber es tut es  Es gibt keinen Zwei- oder Drei-Hit-
Fondor, also okay, also hoffe ich, ich hoffe, es
wird ein Drei-Hit-Wunder, sicher, warum nicht, oder 55
oder 60 ml. Wir stellen auch den Hintergrund
dieser Frage, jetzt kann ich einen angenehmen haben
, okay, ja, wir  hab das angenehme einmal
für mich sind kniffliger als das doch
manchmal bist du ja warum bist du so
selbstbewusst 20 naja das ist schwer ich
weiß nicht ich kann es auch nicht erklären
es ist schon sehr
lange so  und eine sehr lange Zeit, bevor
irgendjemand anderer mir zustimmte, also
weiß ich nicht, ich kann es nicht erklären  Es ist irgendwo in
mir, dass eine Stimme, die mir sagt, dass Sie wissen,
was zu tun ist und dass Sie
selbstbewusst sein müssen, damit ich mich selbst begleiten kann,
ist nicht negativ negativ. Manchmal
verwechseln Menschen Selbstvertrauen mit
Arroganz, aber ich versuche es wirklich  Bleiben Sie auf
der rechten Seite dieser Linie und
ich hoffe, Sie kennen
andere Leute, um zu versuchen, einfach wirklich
glücklich zu sein mit dem, was Sie sind, was Sie tun, und
wieder versuche ich, meine Grenzen zu kennen, aber
ich weiß es auch  was ich tun kann und ich habe versucht, das zu
benutzen gut okay perfekt wir werden
sie alle machen wenn wir können ja weißt du
aber ich dachte warum wähle ich nein nein nein
okay da ich denke es sind zwei mehr als
es ist okay fertig  Es sind noch zwei Wodka
, die auf diesem kniffligen trinken, nichts zu
verlieren,
ja, ist es nicht peinlich für dich, dass
du ein Bürger eines Landes ohne
Regierung bist, ja, absolut, es ist mir
peinlich, ja, ja, absolut, das ist
nur
lächerlich  eine sehr schwierige alice ist
harmlose frage f  Von wem hast du
deine großartige Stimme, das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich wurde damit geboren, also ja, ich denke, sie stammt
von dir, kennst die Familie väterlicherseits.
Ja, mein Vater war ein guter Sänger
und in seiner Familie gibt es viele
Leute mit guter Stimme  oder so ist das
definitiv. Ich denke, dass wir
viele Onkel und Tanten haben. Ich habe gelesen, ja, sie
sind alle gute Sänger. Es hängt davon ab,
wie Sie es definieren, aber es gibt
eine Menge Musik in der Familie, die sehr
wichtig ist, auch wenn es keine
gibt, gibt es keinen Profi  Musiker in der
Familie ist ein wichtiger Teil jap auf
jeden Fall okay okay danke sehr
danke